long live
belarus they chant it was a day of mixed
emotions
on the streets of minsk thousands
gathered for the funeral of a man who
died on monday
in clashes with police at this
demonstration
unusually security forces were nowhere
to be seen
since last sunday's election calls for
president alexander lukashenko to stand
aside have
only grown louder in the face of his
defiance
protesters and the opposition accuse him
of rigging the vote
and say his leadership lacks legitimacy
what will happen remains unclear he
thinks completely differently
and depending how the situation evolves
he will act accordingly
but his methods are not civilized and
everyone has learned this in the last 26
years
[Music]
it is obvious that our president can no
longer cope with his people
he is looking for help in the east he
understands that he does not have
support
from the west
facing mounting pressure lukashenko
called
a powerful neighbor russian president
vladimir putin
warning the protests were not just a
threat to belarus anymore
we are already seeing the steps guiding
a color revolution
in accordance with these guidelines
elements of foreign meddling are already
here
the scenario unwraps with an aggression
against belarus
hours after the phone call with putin
lukashenko said russia had offered its
full assistance to quote
ensure security in the country
well i'm joined now by journalist hannah
yuba kova who's
in minsk hi hannah president lukashenko
says he
has the backing of his ally russian
president vladimir putin now how has
that news been received
where you are in belarus
well he indeed said that russia will
provide security assistance to the ruse
when
luke shenka was respected uh requested
sorry
um well i mean when the news when this
information was announced that luke
shankara is gonna
is going to talk to putin a protester
started bringing banners saying that
we will figure it out here without putin
so
they are all against it they are all
against
russia's intervention but i must say
that um
a chance that russia would invade russia
or intervene uh
belarus will intervene belarus is kind
of um
not really high and i think many people
understand it
though i'd say that people expect some
provocations
or some help from security agencies
in russia in order to to suppress
the dissent in belarus what about the
opposition they have the backing of the
european union do they have
a plan of of how they want
uh political change to come about
oh it's very hard to say few days ago
svetana tikanovska who was
a main challenger to alexander
lukashenka
said that he urged that she would
start she's not um like she can start
negotiating with the borussia government
and she can start working on this
transitional government
in the country but it's very hard to say
well the recent authorities
will not accept it as as we i think um
imagine here
as we guess here um so there are
literally
no way of how to transition
uh the power from from lukashenka to
anyone else and i think lukashenko
is not um willing to do so
and well i mean from what you're saying
how is that affecting the atmosphere
there
uh where you are in minsk i mean we saw
those images of uh
people out on the streets uh for a
seventh day
well people now really want luke shanka
to go
um and yes process has have been
happening for
for the past weeks but also all these
rallies pre-election rallies
in support of sultanate kanoska have
been happening
for weeks before the elections right and
even for months because there were some
protests even before
so this discontent uh has been on the
rise
recently it's not like it started just
on sunday
uh when when the election results were
announced
so um so people don't
want compromise they want lukachenka to
go they want to change the man at the
top
and that's i think the main difference
with what
we could observe in previous years
um and what this project are happening
all across the country so it's not like
the capital is protesting
but smaller towns small cities regional
cities are protesting as well
so it feels like the whole country is on
the rise
and um is protesting against the the
president
hannah yubakova in minsk thanks for your
update
thank you
you